We're now on test number
6 in section 3.
Let's just get started.
Problem number 1.
Which of the following numbers
is between 1/5 and 1/4?
So when you look at the choices,
you immediately see
that all of the numbers
are decimals.
So let's just convert
these to decimals.
1/5 is what?
It's 0.2.
And 1/4 is 0.25.
So we need a number that's
larger-- so let me call it x--
than 0.2 and less than 0.25.
And if you look at the choices,
d is that answer.
And if you didn't know off
hand that 1/5 is 0.2, you
could divide 5 into 1.0.
5 goes into 10 two times.
2 times 10 is 10, 0, and then,
of course, the decimal you
bring up, so it's 0.2 times.
And just do the same
thing with 1/4.
Next problem.
Problem 2.
The following are coordinates
of points in the xy plane.
Which of these points is
nearest the origin?
So if we look at all of the
choices-- well, let me
actually write all
the choices down.
We have a, a says
0, minus 1/2.
b is-- I was thinking whether
I should draw these for you,
but it's good to learn how
to do this without
drawing-- 0, 1/2.
c is 1/2, minus 1/2.
d is 1/2, 1/2.
And e is minus 1, minus 1.
So if we look at all the
choices, we didn't move at all
along the x-axis here, right?
Because we're still
at x equals 0.
We want to figure out how
far it is away from 0.
So we didn't move at all from
the x-axis and we went one
below the y-axis here,
to minus one.
Clearly b is closer than
a because b is
only 1/2 away, right?
Once again, we didn't move on
the x-axis, and we only moved
1/2 away on the y-axis.
So a is not our choice.
So far, b is our
best contender.
It's only 1/2 away
from the origin.
c is 1/2 away in the x direction
and 1/2 away in the
y direction, and if you do
the math, if you use the
Pythagorean theorem, you'll see
that, of course, is going
to be further than 1/2.
And let me just draw a little
bit of a graphic for you just
so you get the intuition.
How I can do that without
drawing it.
So this point is 0, 1/2.
So that point is here.
That's our best contender
right now, 0, 1/2.
The point 1/2, negative
1/2 is here.
See, this is 1/2
minus 1/2 here.
So its distance from
the origin is
this line right here.
And that difference is
definitely going to be longer
than this distance.
How do I know?
Because this distance is the
same thing as this distance,
it's the same thing as 1/2 to
the negative side, right?
And if you do the Pythagorean
theorem, we
could figure it out.
This distance is 1/2
half as well.
This is going to be the square
root of 1/2 squared plus 1/2
squared, so 1/4 plus
1/4, which is 1/2.
So it's the square root of
1/2, which is 1 over the
square root of 2.
Which is the same thing as two
square roots of 2 over 2.
Any way you look at it, it is
a bigger number than 1/2.
When you take a square root of
a fraction, you're going to
get something bigger than
the fraction, right?
So this is essentially the
square root of 1/2.
So it's going to be
bigger than 1/2.
So we know that this
isn't the choice.
And d is the same distance as c,
d is up here, it's just in
the positive quadrant, right?
This distance is 1/2 and then
this distance is 1/2.
So d, for the same reasons,
is further then b.
And e is the furthest
of them all, right?
It's one away in two directions,
so it's out here
someplace relative to
this origin, so
that's not the choice.
So b is definitely the closest,
and it's only 1/2
units away from the origin.
Next problem.
I will change colors
for variety.
Problem 3.
OK, they drew a lot here.
Let me see if I can draw the
same thing they did.
So they have a horizontal
line.
I want to draw just like
the way they did it.
And so then there's
1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
I'm telling you, drawing
it is the hardest part.
And they have something
like this, like that,
and then like that.
And then the next two don't go
all the way through, they go
kind of halfway.
That one goes like that.
And that one.
That's my best shot.
And they say that this is x
degrees, x degrees, x degrees,
x degrees, x degrees, x
degrees, x degrees.
And they say that this big one
right here is y degrees.
In the figure above, what
is the value of y?
Well, the first thing I would
do is figure out what the
value of x is.
And how do I do that?
Well, you could make a whole
circle or whatever, but you
could say look, all of these
x's here, how many is that?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, x's right?
These five x's are collectively
supplementary to
each other, right?
They're going to add
up to 180 degrees.
So we know that 5x is equal
to 180 degrees.
And that x is equal to-- how
many times does 5 go into 180?
5 goes into 150 30 times, and
so there's another 30, so
it'll go into it 36 times.
So x equal to 36 degrees,
you just divide
180 by 5 to get that.
So how do we figure out y?
Well, the easy way to do this
is say well, if you go into
the other side of the circle,
that's also going to be equal
to 180 degrees, right?
So we have two x's here.
And then we have y, right?
So you could say y plus
2x is equal to 180.
I know what x is.
x is 36 degrees, so y
plus 2 times 36 is
72 is equal to 180.
y is equal to 180 minus 72,
which is 108 degrees.
Now, if you wanted to do this
really, really, really fast,
what you could have said
is well, you know what?
If I kept drawing these
x's all the way
around the circle, right?
So let's say that I had
lines like this.
Say this line actually just
continues on like this.
And let's say that this line
continued on like this.
And we know that this is kind
of a visualization exercise,
but you'd have known that this
is x, this is x, this is x.
And then how many x's
total are there?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10.
There would have been
10 x's, right?
And we're going all the way
around the circle, so 10x
would equal 360.
x is equal to 36.
And then a really easy thing,
you could've said well y is 3
of these x's, right?
1, 2, 3.
y is three of those x's,
so three times
36 is equal to 108.
Either way would've been fine.
I think the way we did it the
first time, well, it didn't
take too long, but if you
can do it faster,
that all the better.
Because at some point,
the SAT really just
becomes a speed exam.
Problem number 4.
If 6,565 is equal to 65 times
x plus 1, then x equals?
So the real trick here is being
able to divide fast.
Divide both sides by 65, you
get 65 goes into 6,565 goes
into 65 one time, 1 time 65, 0,
0, 6, goes into it 0 times.
Get a 0, 65, goes into
65 one time.
So you divide both sides
by 65, you get 101 is
equal to x plus 1.
Subtract 1 from both sides,
you get 100 is equal to x.
This is just kind of
a speed problem.
Maybe they want to make you
have a careless mistake.
The answer is c.
I'll see you in the
next video.